.
>> Dana: CONGRATULATIONS TO HIM.
AFTER CRITICS SLAMMED DR.
ANTHONY FAUCI FOR SAYING IT'S
TOO SOON TO TELL IF AMERICANS
CAN GATHER FOR CHRISTMAS.
HE IS NOW WALKING IT BACK.
>> THAT WAS MISINTERPRETED.
I WILL BE SPENDING CHRISTMAS
WITH MY FAMILY AND I ENCOURAGE
PEOPLE, PARTICULARLY THE
VACCINATED PEOPLE WHO ARE
PROTECTED TO HAVE A GOOD,
NORMAL CHRISTMAS WITH YOUR
FAMILY.
>> Dana: SO TYRUS IS HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THIS.
I WATCHED IT.
I DON'T THINK IT WAS
MISINTERPRETED.
HE MIGHT HAVE ANSWERED IT IN A
WAY HE DIDN'T WANT TO ANSWER IT.
THE CLEAR TAKEAWAY ON SUNDAY
WAS IT'S TOO SOON TO TELL IF
YOU CAN SPEND CHRISTMAS WITH
YOUR FAMILY.
>> I'M A GOOD LOOKING WRESTLER,
MAYBE SOME PEOPLE SAY A BIG
DUMB WRESTLER, BUT HOW DO YOU
MISINTERPRET SCIENCE?
IT IS SUPPOSED TO BE JUST THE
FACTS.
HOW DID YOU MISINTERPRET IT?
HE SAID CHRISTMAS WAS CANCELED.
YOU TOOK THE GRINCHES JOB AND
YOU ARE WALKING IT BACK.
WE HAVE MOVED IN MY HOUSE WE'VE
MOVED ON FROM FAUCI.
WE REALIZE WE'RE VACCINATED, WE
TAKE PRECAUTIONS, WE KNOW THERE
ARE SHARKS IN THE WATER AND
WE'RE CAREFUL.
A LOT OF AMERICANS ARE YOU
SHOULDN'T HAVE THIS KIND OF OH,
HAVE TO RESAY THAT.
IT IS SCIENCE.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN YOU
MISINTERPRETED SCIENCE?
MAYBE A MATH PROBLEM.
YOU ARE TELLING US THERE WAS NO
CHRISTMAS AND NOW WALKING IT
BACK.
MAKES ME FEEL LIKE YOU AREN'T
TALKING TO US ABOUT SCIENCE.
>> Dana: THE CDC HAD GUIDANCE
UP THERE ABOUT THE HOLIDAYS.
THEY TOOK IT DOWN AND THEY ARE
EXPECTED THE RE VIEZ THAT.
-- REVISE THAT.
WE HAVE CHRISTMAS AND HALLOWEEN
AND VETERAN'S DAY, THANKSGIVING.
WILL YOU BE CELEBRATING THOSE?
>> THANKSGIVING IS MY FAVORITE
HOLIDAY.
THE ONE TIME I GET TO LET MY
HAIR DOWN AND NOT WORRY ABOUT
CALORIES.
NEXT QUESTION, PLEASE.
>> Dana: THERE IS A POWERBALL
WINNER $700 MILLION.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO IF YOU WON
THE LOTTERY?
>> WHAT WOULD I DO?
>> Dana: HAVE YOU WON LIFE'S
LOTTERY.
>> YES, I WON LIFE'S LOTTERY.
$700 MILLION WOULD BE A
DIFFERENT INTERVIEW TODAY.
I WOULD BE IN A BATH ROBE.
WOULD NOT BE PAYING ATTENTION.
YOU COULDN'T TELL ME ANYTHING.
$700 MILLION REASONS WHY I'M
LATE TO WORK TODAY.
>> Dana: SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T
ALWAYS TURN OUT GREAT FOR
PEOPLE WHO WIN.
>> I'M WILLING TO BET THERE
WILL BE A LOT OF RELATIVES
SHOWING UP.
BEST FRIENDS.
JUST SAY NO.
YOU HAVE TO JUST -- ANY TIME
YOU ARE SUCCESSFUL PEOPLE WILL
COME KNOCKING AT YOUR DOOR.
LONG LOST RELATIVES, PARENTS,
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE WITH
THEIR HANDS OUT.
AS SOON AS YOU START GIVING IT
AWAY, IT WILL BE GONE.
YOU CAN'T LET THEM IN.
STAY WITH WHAT GOT YOU THERE.
STICK TO CLOSE FRIENDS AND
PEOPLE WHEN YOU WERE MAKING
CHOICES BETWEEN THE ELECTRIC
BILL AND GOING TO THE CLUB.
THOSE ARE THE ONES TO KEEP WITH
YOU.
NOT THE ONES WHO WILL SHOW UP.
HE OR SHE IS GOING TO BE VERY
POPULAR.
>> Dana: DO YOU PLAY THE
LOTTERY?
>> NO, MY LIFE IS THE LOTTERY.
>> Dana: YOU WON IT ALREADY.
>> AS OF RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: TRACE, ARE YOU THERE
TO WEIGH IN ON THIS?
>> I'M HERE.
IF I HAD $700 MILLION IS THAT
THE QUESTION OF THE DAY?
I WOULD BUY ME A BOAT AND A
TRUCK TO PULL IT.
>> Dana: WHAT WOULD YOU CALL
YOUR BOAT?
>> WHAT WOULD I CALL IT?
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
>> I WOULD HAVE A
TRUCK/BOAT/TRUCK.
TRUCK, BOAT, PULLING A SMALLER
TRUCK AND THE S.S. I MADE IT.
>> Dana: HE ALWAYS MAKES IT.
$699 MILLIONS.
I SAID $700 MILLION.
TYRUS LAST WEEK, TRACE, HE
DIDN'T COME TO A DINNER IN
NASHVILLE BECAUSE HE WAS THERE
TO TAKE CARE OF HIS DAUGHTER
WHO HAD A MATH TEST AND SHE
PASSED.
SHE ONLY MILLSED ONE.
>> SHE MISSED ONE.
>> WE'RE BOTH GIRL DADS.
YOU ARE A GOOD DAD AND FATHER.
IT WILL BE GREAT STUFF.
IT GETS TOUGHER AS THEY GET
OLDER, JUST REMEMBER THAT.
>> IT'S TOUGH NO